-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
And now we're going to
get to the news.
President Biden
spoke yesterday in Buffalo
and called for
an end to white supremacy.
Well, good luck with that.
You've been in Washington
a year and a half,
and so far,
the only thing Congress
has gotten rid of
is Daylight Saving Time.
[ As Biden ]
Now that we took care of that,
move on to white supremacy.
We crushed Daylight Saving Time.
I mean..."
[ Normal voice ]
President Biden, yesterday,
warned that democracy
is in danger.
Even scarier, in a ransom note.
Former president Trump
recently announced
he is writing a book titled
"The Crime of the Century"
about the alleged voter fraud
in the
2020 presidential election.
Look for it in your bookstore's
Tantrum section.
Pennsylvania Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman
won last night's
Democratic Senate primary.
Pretty impressive for a guy
who looks like
a character from
"Mike Tyson's Punch-Out!!"
He'll now go on to face
Soda Popinski in the general.
North Carolina Representative
Madison Cawthorn, last night,
lost his Republican primary.
Hopefully he will
learn his lesson.
Next time you get invited to
a cocaine orgy, just go.
British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
recently called for Britons
to return to work in person
and said that his experience
working from home
included walking
to the fridge and
"hacking off a
small piece of cheese,"
then forgetting what he's doing.
Well, if it helps,
you're supposed to be serving
as prime minister.
Seems like that job
is big enough that
a little piece of cheese
shouldn't throw you off it.
In a recent interview,
Labor Secretary and former
Boston mayor Marty Walsh
said that Dunkin' Donuts
tasted different
on a recent trip to South Korea.
Said Biden, "You know that's not
why we sent you, right?"
"Here's the report on
the Dunkins."
According to a new poll,
1 in 3 Americans say that
the coronavirus pandemic
is over.
Unfortunately, he's sitting
between the other two.
"Great.
Between a couple of sheep."
Archaeologists in Laos
recently discovered
an ancient tooth,
thought to have belonged to
an extinct human species,
that was lodged in a cave wall.
Experts believed their
last words were, "Not...cake."
He -- He thought...
So, to work backwards,
he thought the wall was cake.
And then he bit it and died.
And, finally, the energy-drink
company Red Bull, last weekend,
held its world paper-airplane
championship,
while Four Loko launched its
first-annual Squid Games.
And that -- that was
the monologue, everybody.